l'entrée en compétition de xavier dolan
c'est un film tout à fait typique de
l'effervescence du cinéma alors c'était
paris tôt ce matin le festival de cannes
dévoilé les titres des films qui ont été
retenus en compétition officielle un
honneur une grande année pour le canada
pour la première fois trois canadiens
sont dans la course et amiens xavier
dolan on viens de l'entendre qu'il ya 25
ans et dans la compétition officielle
avec son cinquième film c'est vraiment
tout un honneur momie et son cinquième
film en six ans ses premiers films
avaient été présentés dans dix volets
parallèle à la compétition à cannes son
quatrième film avait été présenté à
venise et le voilà de retour donc en
compétition entrant par la grande porte
et il a été annoncé ce matin il sera
il y aura comme rivaux et bien de grands
cinéastes mais aussi des canadien david
cronenberg atom egoyan
donc retour sur cette journée émouvante
pour xavier dolan met une journée aussi
historique pour le cinéma de chez nous
merci tanière c'est un rêve qui se
réalise pour xavier dolan
à 25 ans le cinéaste québécois est en
compétition officielle à cannes
ce sera sa quatrième participation au
prestigieux festival en presque autant
d'années
ça va être compliqué d'ailleurs xavier
s'il continue à ce rythme là dans 20 ans
ils ont fait vingt films le plus ces
sommités du cinéma viennent donc de la
faire entrer dans le club sélect des
meilleurs réalisateurs dans le monde
finalement la nouvelle est tombée
fischer puis j'ai appelé à monsieur
barbier est né dans la maison aux piles
et qu'on va voir
ainsi l'actrice anne dorval qui a joué
dans j'ai tué ma mère son premier film
il la retrouve dans mon mis un drame
familial dont on a encore vu aucune
image
le film est dur et crue est assez
impétueux assez violent par moments mais
est aussi un film qui en fait pas aussi
mais surtout un film qui est plein
d'espoir en pleine lumière
on y retrouve aussi suzanne clément qui
a remporté un prix à cannes pour son
rôle dans lawrence anyways un autre film
de dollars on s'en va pas avec
avec notre film sous le bourreau d'hier
on s'en va avec toute la province où le
bon on sait une compétition
internationale c'est la même chose que
c'est les olympiques du cinéma ses
exploits quelqu'un de dire ceci
les olympiques du cinéma pour la toute
première fois à cannes trois cinéastes
canadiens figurent en compétition
officielle
en vain
le torontois david cronenberg présentera
master's un suspense avec julianne moore
atom egoyan un autre habitué de la
croisette concourt pour la palme d'or
avec 14 qui met en vedette ryan reynolds
cette forte présence canadienne
s'explique par la qualité des films
il n'y a pas de lobbying qui peut se
faire c'est vraiment cinéphiles pour foi
de tout donc dans ce dans les trois cas
les faits - étaient soumis les films ont
été visionnés des films ont été choisis
1800 films ont été soumis au festival
celui de denys arcand le règne de la
beauté n'a pas été retenu la compétition
est féroce cette année avec le retour
des frères dardenne de ken loach de jean
luc godard
s'il obtient la palme d'or xavier dolan
sera le plus jeune à obtenir cette
récompense suprême dans l'histoire du
festival
l'important c'est participer ici tanya
lapointe est radio canada montréal